the david pakman show is mostly funded
by
members who sign up at joinpakman.com i
will not waste
any more time talking about it because
we have such a busy agenda
but uh i invite you to grab a membership
at joinedpakman.com where you can also
read about all the great membership
benefits
okay up hatred mail has become managing
the hate mail we have been getting since
joe biden won the election on november
3rd
november 7th as it was called by the
media
it's almost a job in and of itself the
hate mail has so scaled up
and i have one such example for you
today but first a quick reminder what is
hatred mail exactly
last time i checked this was america and
i have the right to share my
droplets with whoever i want
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom right so hatred mail is when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings
of the hate mail that i get and
um here is you know we don't we could do
five shows a week of just an hour of
hate mail at this point we really could
but here is just one example for you to
take a listen to
david pakman is a frustrated loser
the show is circling the drain million
subscribers
50 millions views per month lol
how much did you pay socal blad
almost two years later and david is more
cucked than ever
sore loser yes you
lost spell loser with a d-a-v-i-d
you are a shill and a fraud keep it
up i love those credentials you know i
did
i learned some stuff from the hey i i
didn't realize that we had 50 million
views
in a 30-day period but we we actually
did which is insane and i appreciate
this hatred for uh
for for letting me know about these
stunning numbers i i love it
the part that's confusing to me is what
does we
lost mean like what exactly what what
did we lose
joe biden won right and i i got into an
interesting uh
facebook exchange yesterday against my
better judgment with some friends
uh with so a couple people not my
friends but there are people in the
thread
who believe that trump will be sworn in
for a second term on january 20th and
here's my question to you
should we be betting these people money
and what i mean is
i'm not a betting man i don't really bet
um
but it seems as though there's money to
be made
betting money against the people who say
trump will be sworn in on january 20th
if they really believe that
i'd bet 100 i'd bet a thousand dollars
i'd even look at betting more
but i heard from people who tried this
with family members and they said that
the family members eventually backed out
typically coming up with some excuse
like well listen
it's all rigged like if if it weren't
rigged
trump would be getting sworn in so i'm
no longer participating in the bet which
is of course the point of the bet the
point of the bet
is will trump be sworn in not would
trump be sworn in if right as i said
before
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs she would be a bicycle it's not
well trump would have been sworn in were
it not quote rigged
the bet is will he be sworn in that
seems like easy money to me
but maybe it's taking advantage of
people who can't even think straight let
me know what your thoughts are
and remember that the way to fight
patriotism in your community
is to use the coupon code hatred 40
when you get a membership this is a code
that has been often used
much imitated never equaled hatred 40
saves you 40 at joinpakman.com and it's
spelled h-a-t
r i o t four zero